you may have heard a bunch of things
flying around about tik tok lately
is president trump banning it does
microsoft really want to buy it
are chinese servers collecting user data
on all those dance videos we're posting
we thought it would be good to explain
the basics of what's going on to get you
up to speed
first is president trump trying to ban
tick-tock
the short answer is yes he invoked an
executive order on august 6 that would
take effect in 45 days
any transactions between tick tock's
chinese parent company bite dance
and us citizens or institutions would be
illegal
the trump administration has national
security and data privacy concerns about
tick tock being chinese owned
there are questions over whether or not
trump's executive order is legal
the aclu said the ban would be a danger
to freedom of expression
and npr reported tick tock will be suing
the administration over the ban
second does microsoft want to buy tick
tock
well they're definitely interested or
quote unquote
continuing discussions as they stated in
a press release
tiktok has about 100 million users in
the us
and microsoft is also interested in
tick-tock's operations in canada
australia and new zealand an official
valuation has not been set for tick-tock
but some of bike dance's investors which
include sequoia capital and general
atlantic
put the app's value around 50 billion
dollars
trump who has spoken with microsoft ceo
satya nadella in past weeks
has given the potential microsoft deal
his blessing but
with a catch trump said any acquisition
of tick tock would have to include a
quote-unquote
significant amount of money to the us
government for allowing the deal to take
place
and though microsoft is the front-runner
to buy tick-tock twitter has also
expressed interest
on top of this trump has suggested
oracle could buy tick-tock
and it should be noted oracle founder
and chairman larry ellison
did host a fundraiser for the president
this year
finally how real are the concerns over
the chinese government's access to
tick-tock user data
officially the app is not owned by or
partnered with the chinese government
but it has been accused of censoring
content that mentioned topics sensitive
to the chinese communist party
such as the protests in hong kong the
country's treatment of the uyghur
population in xinjiang the tiananmen
square protests
or tibetan independence in october 2019
republican senator marco rubio called
for an investigation as to whether or
not tiktok posed
a national security risk the new york
times reported it has spoken with an
anonymous source who said the u.s
government has
evidence ticktock is sending user data
back to china
but tiktok maintains that american user
data is kept in the united states with a
backup server in singapore
it also denied it removes content that
is sensitive to chinese government
interests
you